joséphine quand même ce berger bonsoir
pense à vous êtes la maire sortante les
républicains de plaisir vous serez
candidate pour un troisième mandat dans
la ville où vous avez été élu pour la
première fois en 2012
il est resté à trancher le nom de votre
liste c'est chose faite désormais speedy
l'avant ce désir avance pour cette liste
alors votre candidature a reçu
l'investiture de la majorité de droite
départementale ensemble pour les
yvelines à laquelle vous appartenez on
précise que vous êtes également
conseillère départementale vice
présidente du conseil départemental et
aussi de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous êtes aussi adhérente au parti des
républicains est ce que cette liste
portera cette couleur où elle va réunir
diverses sensibilités dans cette liste
qui est renouvelée à un plus de 50% avec
énormément de jeunes qui ont voulu nous
rejoindre et bien il y aura la majorité
de non inscrits il y aura des personnes
de pas mal de bord y compris aux
démarcheurs puisque la liste est
complète
aujourd'hui si la liste est complète et
bien sûr elle est prête depuis un moment
puisque nous avons commencé au mois
d'avril
et aujourd'hui on a je dirais presque
trop de monde autour de nous mais en
tout cas ce sont des personnes qui même
s'ils ne seront pas dans les hisseront à
côté de nous ce sont des sympathisants
on est actuellement dans une permanence
dans laquelle il ya une beaucoup
d'énergie et beaucoup de l'ambiance
positive et je le disais vous avez été
élu pour la première fois en 2012
prenant la suite de joël regnault qui
avait démissionné à l'époque vous avez
été élus en 2014 au premier tour
pourquoi être candidate pour un
troisième mandat sera le second sur
lequel vous briguez en tout cas un
second mandat complet je pense que quand
on prend en main je dirais une ville qui
a eu une vraie continuité depuis 2001 et
qui a mis en place des projets vraiment
aux fondamentaux et des projets de
dynamisme au niveau de la ville et bien
les grands projets en tout cas ont
besoin au moins de deux mandats pour
arriver au bout on a des projets qui
sont des projets très structurant sur la
ville qui sont des projets surtout sur
la protection des espaces verts puisque
nous avons des déménagements qui vont
nous libérer 20 hectares en centre ville
donc c'est un vrai enjeu est en même
temps un atout et puis également on a
des projets vous savez comme l'art
fonte complète du quartier du vélib ou
mais également le centre bourg c'est
quelque chose qui nous semble
fondamental d'accompagner puisque nous
avons enclenché tout ça sur ce premier
mandat
mais si vous regardez votre dernier
mandat le bilan que vous faites un bilan
avec de nombreux projets des projets
encore à mener pour les écouter on le
bilan va bientôt sortir dans quelques
jours il va être entre les mains des
plaisirs hu à plus de 98% des choses
auraient été faites y en a fait même des
choses supplémentaires que nous n'avions
pas prévu puisque nous avons été pendant
toute cette mandature l écoute des
plaisirs roi avec bien sûr des réunions
comme on a toujours fait mais aussi
parce que la société a changé pendant
cette période et on s'est rendu compte
que les priorités qui était bien
présente en 2014 ne sont plus les mêmes
et donc on s'est adapté pendant cette
mandature avec quelques tensions entre
eux mêmes dans votre majorité les
dernières en date on rappelle en
septembre dernier trois de vos anciens
adjoints ont rejoint l'opposition
patrick jean terre notamment qui sera
candidat face à vous ils ont dénoncé à
l'époque des divergences de points de
vues sur la gestion et l'orientation de
la ville est ce que c'est un regret
quand vous regardez votre mandat qui eut
ces tensions au sein de votre nom je
m'interroge surtout sur la période de
démission qui est une période 1 5 mois
des élections je pense que quand on a
des divergences dans une équipe on
parvient plutôt un an deux ans trois ans
avant on se rend compte assez vite que
les choses ne vont pas mais quand on a
tout voté ensemble à l'unanimité ça peut
paraître étonnant que tout à coup à cinq
mois des élections et bien il ait des
divergences et des départs en même temps
je dirais le départ de monsieur jean
terre si je peux le citer et et bien il
est d'autant plus étonnant que c'est un
départ qui n'est pas vraiment de sa
volonté puisque cet été j'ai appris
qu'il montait une liste contre moi je
lui ai demandé de démissionner donc il a
anticipé les parties donc je pense
qu'effectivement nous n'avions rien plus
rien à faire ensemble
votre programme pour plaisir qui sera
articulée autour de quatre axes majeurs
un point notamment sur l'écologie c'est
un enfant qu'on voit notamment émerger
de nombreuses communes c'est on peut pas
faire sans aujourd'hui non on peut pas
faire ça on s'en rend compte c'est pas
simplement une priorité collective je
dirais sur une sur une ville c'est
collectif au niveau national voire
international
on doit absolument accompagner cette
démarche là c'est une vraie volonté on
le sent et puis je pense que on a la
chance d'avoir une ville comme plaisir
qui est une ville à plus de 50% de
ruralité il faut la maintenir et la
développer donc c'était déjà un argument
que nous avions pris en 2014
et aujourd'hui non seulement est quelque
chose qu'on veut continuer mais qui est
vraiment attendu par la population et
donc on sera là pour continuer toutes
les démarches qu'on a mis en place et
l'écologie en tout cas c'est l'ambition
affichée pour le renouvellement du
quartier du val hibou qui a vocation à
devenir un éco quartier exactement dans
non seulement les 65 millions d'euros
que nous avons réussi à avoir pour ce
quartier pour cette modification en
profondeur de ce quartier qui va non
seulement transformé le quartier du val
hibou mais l'ensemble de la collectivité
parce que ça va avoir un impact bien sûr
écoquartier ça nous semblait
indispensable il s'était aussi attendu
par les habitants puisque aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être un peu minérale il est
important pour voir les choses
différemment
et puisqu'on parle de ce quartier du val
et booth et il a été touchée récemment
par quelques soirées de violence urbaine
qu'est le travail est fait justement par
la commune quel travail est à mener
encore pour faciliter cette tranquillité
publique à la favoriser justement le
fait je dirais d'avoir six
accompagnement financier pour changer le
quartier c'est une chose mais est
important aussi d'avoir une série
d'actions comme par exemple nos
médiateurs nous avons des médiateurs qui
sont des agents de la ville qui
travaille sur les quartiers des
relations et des collaborations étroites
avec bien sûr les associations qui sont
du quartier mais également d'éclat
mosquée puisque c'est quand même un
élément important il faut savoir que
tous les partenaires qui sont sur ce
quartier sont des personnes qui ont une
véritable un véritable engagement sur
les quartiers et aujourd'hui avec les
médiateurs la police municipale la
police nationale également qui n'est pas
qualifie d'homme jeudi annick est pas un
corps qui vient uniquement là je dirais
pour pour m une inquiétude bien au
contraire
et puis aussi parce que les
transformations profondes que nous
allons faire dans ce quartier ont
véritablement changé la configuration du
quartier cette ouverture
ça y est de constater que si l'eau est
tombé et donc ce silo ouvre déjà le
quartier à l'ensemble de la ville
puisque comme je les ai toujours dit le
valley bout
est un quartier au coeur de la ville et
c'est un atout fondamental plaisir qui a
connu au cours de ce dernier mandat
l'intégration dans saint quentin en
yvelines depuis le 1er janvier 2016
la commune fait partie de cette
agglomération vous en êtes la première
vice présidente est ce qu'on peut parler
d'intégration réussie ou est-ce qu'il
faut renforcer encore davantage ce
travail mené avec l'agglomération
je parle de d'intégration et également
de décentralisation c'est quelque chose
aujourd'hui qui est entre les mains même
du président de la république et du
sénat avec gérard larcher nous
travaillons là dessus
il est évident que nous sommes
actuellement bien intégré au niveau de
saint quentin on arrive à trouver je
dirais des énergies communes
il faut qu'on trouve un projet commun
qui est un projet qui réunisse les douze
communes on en a véritablement le
potentiel moi je sais que depuis
longtemps je défends un projet de
territoire aujourd'hui bien sûr c'est
attendu par tout le monde par tous les
maires j'imagine que nous serons à même
de le faire ensemble après les élections
pour encore une fois est bien mutualiser
davantage
et puis trouver des éléments encore plus
important pour pouvoir avoir des moyens
financiers parce que comme vous le savez
les collectivités seules aujourd'hui
avec les baisses de dotations et bien on
a beaucoup de mal à s'en sortir
je pense que ça peut être une
possibilité d'aller de l'avant
un dernier mot sur vos prochains rendez
vous de campagne joséphine coleman ce
verger
quels sont-ils quand allez-vous
rencontrer la population plaisir aux
mais je suis déjà j'ai reconstruit la
bourgeoisie en liant le vis bien sûr
nous avons deux rendez vous mais je fais
des rencontres tous les jours avec
déplaisir hoa dans des familles dans des
groupes de personnes qui m'accueille
mais en même temps si vous le permettez
j'aurais tendance à dire que depuis 2012
c'est ma façon de fonctionner je suis
sur le terrain en permanence et donc
c'est pas parce qu'il ya la campagne
municipale que tout à coup je me mets
rencontrait les plaisirs donc c'est une
continuité avec peut-être des précisions
un peu plus grands de notre bilan parce
que tout n'est peut-être pas visibles et
compréhensibles et puis nos prochaines
rencontres donc c'est au cosy et on a on
un restaurant qui nous accueille et puis
également à la trattoria au gastines ce
sont deux rendez vous qui sont sur notre
site puisque nous avons un site qui est
important d'aller visiter parce qu'il ya
pas mal d'informations dessus et puis je
peux vous dire que notre campagne sera
respectueuse elle sera souriante
dynamique et puis l écoute des plaisirs
roi comme nous l'avons toujours été avec
je dirais aucune agressivité
merci josefina coleman berger maire
sortante de plaisir vous serez candidate
pour un troisième mandat face à vous
pour le moment une autre candidature
officielle celle de patrick jean terre
remettons plaisir en marche c'est le nom
de sa liste et je précise également
qu'un appel a été lancé par le groupe
nous plaisir rendre la ville à ses
habitants pour constituer une liste
citoyenne pas d'officialisation encore
sur cette candidature